you can smell their breath I know you're
a big on dog yeah I love it so much
today we're going to be guessing dog
breeds
no oh like we don't get to see the doll
this is so much harder well I came in
what do you sauces this is dog very long
snout is it a cat or like a rat or
something is this a joke giant rat
is it a dachshund I think she's a leaner
doggie Oh totally like I think the
features of that dog were pretty easy to
guess the long body the short hair I'm
actually feeling better about this now
hi you got a dog yeah oh so soft
oh you're a big guy you're like a really
big guy yeah you're a big you're a big
old buckaroo there
he's got tiny little ears little bit
coarser fur a good good little belly
good tush yeah good
I wouldn't know according it's not a
quarry he has short little ears I swear
to God if it's a fox or something like
that cuz that would be really cool is it
a fox sukira
Geneva Sheba yeah the short little snout
short little ears no tail she's a beauty
usually the Doge we got two for two oh
we are dogs let's guess more fur babies
[Music]
alright alright we're dealing with a lot
of fur this is a golden retriever yeah
I'm gonna go with a retriever I don't
know this is like a bear
Oh is stylish Manila bandana feel like
we have a similar style hey smells
smells pretty good for a dog I I think
I'm wrong I think this might be like
some kind of a wolf dog Game of Thrones
it's practical yeah can I get a kiss
that was quite the experience a day that
starts with doggies is a day that's okay
with me
I think when you're put to the test your
dog breed knowledge will surprise you
I don't mind dog breath that breath is
good yeah it's good it's just one man's
opinion dog breath is good